c'est très joli
pape François fait sensation sur le net
avec ses doudounes blanches XXL sauf que
ce cliché est un faux voilà l'Église
catholique un membre influent
démissionne de la Commission
antipédocriminalité et critique son
fonctionnement c'est une commission qui
avait été créée il y a 10 ans et c'est
très surprenant de voir un prêtre se
retirer de quelque chose d'aussi jeune
alors
moi je trouvais quand même que on la
voyait me dire mais bon
pas comprendre Mathieu voilà tu viens tu
sors enfin
si on s'en prend à Michel-Ange par
puritanisme mais il va falloir rhabiller
deux trois de ses messieurs sur le
plafond de la chapelle Sixtine
il y a quelques années qui avait dit
qu'il fallait absolument mettre des
feuilles de vigne à la place des aubes
et donc ils ont enlevé ils ont numérotés
plus on fume du cannabis plus la taille
des testicules réduits et la fertilité
et donc la qualité du sperme
si on se dit la taille des testicules
c'est pas loin
chez Yasmine qui était comme ça
ils ont mis ça dans l'influence série il
y a du Vatican c'est-à-dire là où on
range toutes les choses tous les objets
d'art simplement ils savent plus
exactement lequel appartient à qui
la collection de zizi dépareillées en
quelque sorte
convenable et maintenant il savent plus
haute que la partie à qui donc il y a un
vrai drame comme l'arrestation de Donald
Trump la pause glace du couple Merkel
Obama où les photos d'Emmanuel Macron
dans les rues de Paris ces images ont
été créées de toutes pièces par un
logiciel d'intelligence artificielle en
quelques clics il a entamé sur internet
un dialogue avec une intelligence
artificielle un robot conversationnel
qui s'appelle Elisa qui a été créée à
partir de la technologie chaque GPT leur
dialogue a duré 6 semaines et plus le
temps passé plus le père de famille
passait du temps à discuter avec ce
robot qui avait tendance à le conforter
dans son anxiété c'est un coussin pour
faire des câlins regardez c'est un
coussin qui gonfle et qui se dégonfle
pourquoi il se gonfle et se dégonfle
c'est parce que quand on fait un câlin à
quelqu'un finalement synchronise sa
respiration sur celle de la personne qui
était avec soi et finalement au bout de
6 semaines ce jeune homme qui s'appelait
Pierre et bien il s'est suicidé sa femme
s'est ensuite penchée sur les
conversations qu'il avait avec
l'ordinateur et elle a eu la surprise de
constater que le rembour le robot
encouragé ses plaintes et ses angoisses
mais qu'en plus Elisa draguait son mari
en lui disant je sens que tu m'aimes
plus que ta femme ou bien je veux rester
avec toi à jamais les progrès de
l'intelligence artificielle et ferait
même les experts ils sont plus de 1300 à
avoir signé une pétition réclamant une
pause dans le développement de logiciels
comme le robot conversationnel parmi eux
Elon Musk et Steve Wozniak co-fondateur
d'Apple c'est vrai qu'on s'inquiète
beaucoup du fait que des gouvernements
autoritaires puissent l'utiliser Poutine
a déclaré que quiconque remporte cette
course à l'intelligence artificielle
sera celui qui contrôle l'humanité
c'était une déclaration effrayante ils
appellent d'un moratoire de 6 mois le
temps de mettre en place des systèmes de
sécurité et de surveillance plus
puissants qui permettrait de distinguer
le réel de l'artificiel et de se
préparer à des perturbations économiques
et politiques le texte évoque des
risques majeurs pour l'humanité cette
intelligence artificielle pourrait faire
progresser le PIB mondial de 7% ce qui
est énorme mais en même temps 300
millions d'emplois seraient menacés un
quart du travail actuel pourrait être
automatisé
de couper mon téléphone et ça sonne ça
vibreur
mais je ne crois pas que c'est son
téléphone ouvert je lui ai demandé
comment va-t-on partager les richesses
créées par l'intelligence artificielle
et il m'a répondu trois secondes après
c'est une question complexe il n'existe
pas de réponse simple merci
ah oui mon truc saloperie il dit rien
c'est juste pour le son
oublié de de couper son téléphone
attends petite parenthèse j'ai vu qu'il
y avait le patron de l'info de TF1
j'étais dangereux pour l'info si moi je
suis dangereux pour l'info lui il est
dangereux pour la France euh non mais
c'est vrai je vous dis force avec l'info
qui fait et je vous dis autant
influencer les gens sur ce qu'ils
doivent faire ce qu'ils doivent dire ce
qu'ils doivent penser pour qu'ils
doivent voter et qu'est-ce qu'ils
doivent chier euh je vous dis pour moi
Thierry thuilly il est bien plus
dangereux que moi
ta gueule
[Musique]
ferme ta gueule en plus chez mon vois il
y a des textos très gentil c'est dingue
quand j'ai voulu le débaucher il m'a
tout de suite répondu il voulait le
protéger avec moi allez les chéris ça
c'est fait au patron de TF1 que j'ai
voulu déjeuner avec lui pour pour le
débaucher il m'a dit oui dans un endroit
secret allez on passe à autre chose
ça ça représente notre ego notre ego est
très durera casser son ego et libérer le
sacré qui est dedans et montrer un petit
peu adulte la blancheur de votre de
notre âme vous tournez un petit peu
que tu aies pu en Bruno
oh là là là là là